- [Interviewer] All right, Flakah.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Flakah,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Flakah] I grew up in Long Beach.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
You had both of your
parents when you were a kid?
- No.
Grew up with my mother and a stepfather.
He's actually been in our lives
for since I was a little girl.
But before that, it was just
like random ass guys, you know?
Typical shit your parents do,
leave you at home type shit or whatever.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
- It was pretty fucked up.
For whatever reason,
I was always being attacked by my mother.
We never really got along.
It was always just, you know,
whatever happened in the
household with another sibling,
it was always my fault.
And you know, it was just,
it was kind of fucked up.
And then that's when she got my stepdad
and they used to get,
well, they used to party
every weekend, you know?
Leave Friday, whatever,
party all night 'til Sunday, come home.
Sleep all day on Sunday.
And at that time,
I probably was like in
like the fourth grade,
maybe third or fourth grade.
And they had a friend that
used to come over with them
and he pretty much just tried
to take advantage of me.
You know, I had my clothes down.
He was trying to like
offer me money to like--
- [Interviewer] And how old were you?
- I was young.
I was like six or seven,
somewhere around there.
Like between those ages.
I'm not really sure.
I don't remember.
But I remember I was scared
and I told my cousin.
And she's like, "You gotta tell your mom."
And I was like, you know,
it wasn't one of those
things where, you know,
you can go tell your mom like,
look, this is happening to me you know?
And so I kept it to myself
until it happened to my cousin
and then she told my mom.
And then she was like,
yeah, he did it to Flakah too or whatever.
And then I got in trouble.
I got in trouble.
So like, you know, when you're that small,
you don't know what fuck's going on.
You don't know why shit is happening.
You know?
And if somebody else is touching on you
and the one person who was
supposed to be protecting you
like talks shit to you and yells at you
because you didn't say shit
instead of actually protecting you,
it's like it kind of
puts a wall up for you.
So, you know, like that's
kind of how it all started.
I started drinking at nine,
started smoking weed at nine.
My mother had came.
She moved and she left me
and my brother with my grandmother,
so we kinda just did whatever we want.
You know, I'm like my grandma's favorite,
so she never questioned anything I did,
anywhere I went, who I was around.
And that's kind of where
everything started.
- [Instructor] So your mom was into drugs?
- Yeah.
She won't admit it,
but she was into drugs.
Like she wasn't a full on addict.
You know, she was like a
functional addict here and there,
but she learned how to stop
or however she did it, but.
- [Interviewer] And your dad?
- My dad was a full-blown
addict, a full-blown.
I used to get high with my dad.
Well, my stepdad, but I call him my dad.
But when we moved to Long Beach,
that's when like kind of
everything just started,
like started hanging around
with different people,
getting into trouble, fights.
I didn't really care, you know?
Like I had a mother who was more involved
with her dude than her kids.
And then my stepdad had kids
and he has a lot of kids,
so it was like a bunch
of us all, you know.
At one point, it was all
of us in one household
and it was just chaotic.
I used to come home high every day.
My mother never knew.
My stepdad never knew
'cause I would just go
straight to the room
and just block everything out.
I was always in trouble.
I was always grounded.
If I answered the door when I was grounded
and my parents walk in,
I'm grounded again for being at the door.
You know, it's just like
little shit like that.
It's like as a little girl,
it's like, what the fuck am I doing wrong?
Like, what is it?
Like, what's going on, you know?
But it's like back in
the days, you don't talk.
Like, parents don't talk to
their kids like that, you know?
There's no DCFS or this,
like how they have all these rules now.
So it's like everything just
gets swept under the carpet
and you just keep on moving.
So I left at 14,
got with my first baby's dad,
got pregnant at 15.
That was (indistinct).
That was just like a whole
'nother life right there.
Just being pregnant at 15 is,
I mean, it's a scary ass thing, you know?
I got kicked out of
school for being pregnant
because they were scared
that I was gonna influence the
other girls to be pregnant.
So I spent a little time out,
like, you know, not going to school.
Then I found a school where
I can go while I'm pregnant
and also have my kid there.
So I started doing that.
My baby's dad was into gangs,
so by the time my son was like two months,
he went to jail for 20 years.
So I raised my son on my own.
For like the first year or two,
I was working, I was going to school.
I was doing my internship for RN.
You know, I was on my shit,
but I was still partying every weekend,
still drinking every weekend.
Always had my son.
Never neglected him, never did nothing.
You know, he was always G'd up.
Like I never, you know?
I was a really mean mother.
Everything was not pretty and shit,
but that's when I met my second baby's dad
and that's where like
everything just went to shit.
I have four kids now.
From the moment I had my first daughter,
that's when I started using meth.
And it was just an everyday thing,
an everyday all day thing.
House was always dirty.
You know, the kids were fed,
they went to school and all that,
but it was a whole 'nother side of neglect
for the kids, you know?
Shit that I experienced as a child
that I never wanted to bring to my kids.
And it's exactly what I did
and I did it 10 times worse.
So that went on for a few years.
The whole DCFS got
involved, lost the kids,
got them back, lost them again.
Just, I mean, I don't know.
It's just been chaos.
It's been chaos.
You know, going in and out of jail.
Using dope, selling dope,
doing all kinds of illegal activities
that I will not repeat, but--
- [Interviewer] So you
joined a gang eventually?
- [Flakah] No, I never joined the gang.
I never joined.
I was always the type to,
I'm always against authority,
so like even in a gang,
it's like you have rules.
You have certain places you can't go,
certain people you can't talk to.
And I'm just everywhere.
I don't care.
I'll talk to whoever, you know?
If I see that you're cool.
Like, you know, if we
could do a job together,
like we'll do it.
Most of the time, I do my jobs on my own
because I don't like nobody
knowing what I'm doing.
There's always snitches around, so.
- [Interviewer] But no jail time?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] No prison time?
- I've never actually been to prison,
but I've been to jail
a whole lot of times.
This last time, I was like going on three.
I just got out like two and
a half, three years ago.
I did 11 months for a whole gang of dope
that I got caught up with it.
It wasn't mine.
It was actually family member's
and a guy that I was
messing with at that time.
And I had my kids with me,
but it was like, I had no record.
And you know, my dude or whatever he was,
who I was messing with at the time,
like he would have went
to jail for a long time.
My family member would
have did a lot of time
and then got deported.
So in order to kind of
save them and everything
and not make it such a big deal,
I took the fall for everything.
And yeah, I went to jail.
They got me for intent to distribute
because I only had the dope.
I didn't have a scale, no bags,
no money, no none of that,
so they couldn't get me for sales,
but they gave me two and a half
and I ended up doing 11 months.
But it's just,
I think with the whole,
that whole thing that went down,
you know, that's when
detectives get involved
and they try to sit you down.
It's like a real life,
like how you see it in the movies
when they sit you at table and two chairs
in an empty ass room.
You know, he's like, sit down,
and he's like, we can
make all this go away.
And I was just like, no.
I'm good, you know?
Fuck you, like.
He's like, you just got to do three jobs.
I was like, I'm good.
Look, I know what I did.
I admitted it.
Just give me my time, you know.
And so the consequences of that
was like me basically losing my kids.
- [Interviewer] They wanted
you to be an informant?
- Yeah.
And I just, I couldn't do it.
So I got bailed out.
And when I went to court,
I had that dude that I was
messing with at the time,
he went with me.
And even my attorney
or the public defender,
he was like, you know,
can I talk to you like
on the side or whatever?
So we kind of moved to the side,
but like, the dude was still
sitting there so he can hear.
And he's like, okay, so
you're helping the detective.
And I was like, no, the fuck I'm not.
'Cause it could be any
little thing they say
and it's like, anybody hears it.
Like, that's it.
You're burnt, you're done.
You know?
And I was like, nah, fuck that.
Take that off my record.
I'm not helping no fucking detective,
none of that shit.
Like, just give me my time.
'Cause he's like, well, I can't help you.
You know?
I was like, I don't care.
I'm not asking you to help me.
Just give me my time and that's it.
You know?
I didn't ask for your help.
Just tell the judge
whatever needs to be said
and that's it.
Give my time and I'll be out of your way.
And he was like, all right.
And I think that's the
first time I ever got scared
as far as like dealing with
the whole gang environment
because people don't play when
it comes to shit like that.
And I'm definitely not no informant.
And, I mean, as far as the way I grew up
and the people I grew up around,
that's just something you don't do.
I know the game has been
washed up a little bit,
but you know, my values,
all the rules I go by
are from back in the day.
It's just, you know?
That's kind of why I'm still
doing the same shit like now.
Tomorrow, I'll be 33.
And I was in a program.
I literally snuck out last
night to go see my dude.
And that went all bad.
And then I'm back here at skid row,
fucking same shit, back
and forth, back and forth,
because it's like you want to do good,
but you know, all the damage,
all the chaos you've caused in your past,
it's like there's barriers.
There's obstacles you've gotta go through
and it's not always easy for a female.
And so, yeah, like I just, you know.
- [Interviewer] Did you raise any kids?
- I raised them for the first few years.
My youngest one is probably the only one
that I didn't really raise.
She was a year when they took her from me.
And it was so stupid too
because I had been clean.
I was clean and the social worker came
and they had been trying
to get ahold of me.
They were living with
their dad at the time
and I was just kind of everywhere.
And they were like, you know,
we need you to come in and test.
And I had been clean for like
at least three, four days.
And the day of the test,
I went and got high.
And it was like, who the fuck
thinks of shit like that?
Like your whole case
could have been closed
if you would've just waited to go test
and then go get high or
not get high, you know?
But that's just how
fucking addict minds think,
or we don't think.
We just do.
- [Interviewer] Do you think
there's some self-destructive streak
that just makes you kind
of sabotage yourself?
- Yeah, all the time.
We were talking about this
in rehab the other day,
like, you know, just self-destruction,
self-sabotage,
fear of not knowing if I can succeed
or if I can make shit happen.
Like, yeah.
So it makes you just not want to do it.
It makes you not want to try it.
And it's easier to just fuck everything up
'cause I know my kids are good,
like well taken care of.
They're in the system,
but they're not in the system.
You know, they've always been with family.
So I think I use that like
to just be like, fuck it.
Like, I can't give them nothing right now.
Like, I can't give them a home.
I can't feed them.
I can't do shit,
so I just kind of go with that.
And I know I shouldn't,
but that goes along with just guilt
and the shit I've put them through,
the shit they've seen.
And it's no shit that kids
should never see, you know?
Like sitting here taking a gang of pills
trying to kill myself,
and the kids are looking at me
like what's going on with mom?
And rushing me out the
house to the hospital.
And it's like kids don't
need to see like that.
It was just so much
violence, so much violence.
My kids seen a lot of violence.
And I'm talking about
not just going heads up.
I mean, like destroying the whole house,
you know, barricading
yourself in the house,
throwing knives,
stabbing, like everything.
Had them living in room to room.
Like, it's like shit that kids
don't need to see, you know?
So right now, I feel like
I'm living out my karma type,
you know?
Who knows?
Maybe God has something
different for me later on,
but for right now.
I mean, I've even lied to my parents.
I was like, I'm not gonna leave.
This is the last time.
I've never had a
breakthrough with my mother.
And when I was at the
rehab a couple of days ago,
like I finally text her.
And in all honesty,
I only text her 'cause I knew
she was gonna bring me money,
and cigarettes, and stuff like that.
So I was like, let me
just hit her up real quick
and so I did.
But it was like a whole 'nother experience
because as soon as I hit her up,
you know, it was just a quick text.
She was at work.
And she was like, asking if I was okay,
why haven't I hit her up or whatever.
And then she was like,
when I get off of work,
I'm gonna call you.
And I'm over here,
like well don't call me
because I'm not supposed
to have a phone in rehab,
but I do.
So just text me and I'll call you.
So she calls me and she's crying.
And for me, for my mother to cry
because of the shit I'm doing
is something I've never like experienced.
We never had that bond, you know?
So she's like, you know what?
You know you are my daughter.
You think I don't love you?
You don't think I don't worry?
And like, that shit made me cry
only 'cause we've never had that.
So I'm just like, damn.
Like, I really am a fucked up ass.
Like, she pays for my phone.
Like, she's been paying for my phone
since I got out of jail.
It's going on three years.
I don't give her shit for the phone
and I got a brand new phone.
Like, I don't pay the bill every month
and she just keeps paying.
Sure enough, she was like,
I'm gonna take you cigarettes,
I'm gonna take you money,
I'm gonna take you food.
And I was like, I'm not
gonna leave this time.
It's different.
Like, you know?
And here the fuck I am
again back on Skid Row
and she don't even know it yet,
but I mean, I don't know.
Being an addict is fucked up.
Like we don't ever think
about the consequences
or the people we hurt when
we're in our addiction,
you know?
- [Interviewer] Have you
been through rehab a lot?
- Yes.
It's like at least my ninth,
10th time being in rehab.
I've completed only two times.
The rest is just either
I'm about to complete it
and I fuck up,
or I'm just like, you know what, I'm out.
Which that's mostly what it is.
It's like I get there and
stay there a day or two.
And it's like, all right, I'm gone.
This last time,
I probably went back
like six times already
in the last month.
And that's only 'cause
I'm tired of being here on the streets.
And I think this last run
was probably the first time
I've ever actually been on Skid Row,
like actually in it.
And it's just, it's a crazy experience.
But you know,
my mom always says if I could
just slap you out of it,
you'll be good.
And I'm just like,
well, if you can slap
the addiction out of us,
then nobody would be addicts.
Like, you know, we
wouldn't have this problem,
but you know, here we are.
So, I mean, I don't know.
I didn't really go into much details, but.
- [Interviewer] Do you think
that the problem is the addiction
or do you think it's the low self-worth,
what you believe,
you believe you deserve crap so you?
- I think it's more of the lifestyle
because I mean, I just
had a breakthrough too
with the whole like guilt and
and feeling like, you know,
the fear of the unknown for the future.
You know, if I get my kids
back, will I lose them again?
But I think it's more
of like the lifestyle
because I mean, there's
times where I have done good.
I was with a guy.
We moved to Tracy.
We had a five-bedroom house, cars.
The kids went to like the
best white school, you know?
Schools where you gotta, like,
it's not an option for you
to donate to the school.
It's an obligation, you know?
And I've had a good life, you know?
Here and there.
But there's times where I was, I was good.
And it's still, it's still the lifestyle.
The lifestyle is like, you know,
I'm in an area where I don't know nobody.
And I always feel like
I gotta defend myself,
so if somebody comes at me talking proper
or saying some stuff that
I don't really understand,
like I'll take it as
like they're attacking.
And it's not.
It's just 'cause like I'm
so close minded sometimes
that I don't try to
understand the next person.
And I'm just so quick to, you know,
like fuck it.
Like, all right, so what's next?
You know, like move on.
And I'm really good at leaving, you know?
Like if something don't go right
or if I fuck it up enough,
I'm gone, you know?
And I'll disappear for
like couple of days,
couple of weeks, couple years,
come back and start the
process all over again.
Start doing good,
then realize, all right, I'm doing good.
Like, you know, I can get high real quick
or I could go make this
quick money or whatever.
And then that's when it starts all over
and just start losing
shit little by little
until I'm back here.
And that's just kind of how it's been
for the past 12, 13, 14 years.
And I wish I could say like, this is done,
but I don't know because I know inside,
I do want to feel,
like I do feel like this is over now
and I want to turn my life around,
but then it's like any
little thing will happen.
Like for instance, you know, this morning,
like I'm over here chilling
with this dude or whatever.
And because he's coming
down off of his shit,
we kind of get into it.
And then now it's like, well, fuck it,
I'm not going back to the program.
And I still have a chance to go back
without them knowing I left.
But it's like, look
where I end up, you know?
End up here fucking getting high.
And it's just, it's crazy, it's crazy.
This addiction is real.
It's powerful.
- [Interviewer] What do you think
most people don't
understand about addiction
that are not addicts?
- I think the biggest
thing they struggle with
is just not understanding,
like not understanding
what the drug does to you
as far as your body, your mind,
as far as the whole craving,
like releasing dopamine, all of that.
They get into all of the
details when you're in rehab,
but it's like when you're not an addict,
or even for the addicts who
like are functional addicts
or like occasional addicts, you know,
even they don't understand.
It's kinda like having a sugar craving,
a chocolate craving or
whatever, or a hobby.
Like, it's like if you like biking,
it's like you don't know why you do it.
I mean, well, you know why you do it,
but whatever feeling it gives you,
that's what makes you
want to keep doing it.
You know?
People that hike, people that golf.
It just makes you feel a certain way
and that is exactly what dope does.
- [Interviewer] It becomes
your first priority.
- Right.
It's not even like second nature.
It's like just first
nature type shit, you know?
- [Interviewer] It seems
like more than survival.
- Right.
And then you got the drugs
that make you actually physically sick
if you don't keep using, you know?
The type where your whole
body could shut down.
Luckily, meth is not like that.
It's just, you sleep for a couple of days
and you wake up and you're good.
You might feel a little weak
'cause you're overworking your body,
but there's no actual physical pain
where you need to like
be medicated or whatnot.
So that's why I always feel
like I don't have it that bad,
but I mean, any drug that you do is bad.
It doesn't matter how
bad it makes you feel
when you're coming off of it or not.
It's about where it takes you
while you're in your addiction, you know?
And it's just, people do crazy shit.
You'd be surprised like the shit,
this whole past year,
the shit I've been going through,
the shit I put up with
just because the dope.
Like all the fighting,
all the getting beat up.
Like, it's just, it's crazy,
but for whatever reason, we deal with it.
We accept it.
We live it.
We give that same negative
energy to the next person
and it's all because we
just want to be high.
- [Interviewer] Do you feel
like it's a generational curse?
- It's maybe not a curse.
It's more of like,
I mean, I guess you
could see it as a curse.
- [Interviewer] I see it as role models.
The role models you had--
- Well, yeah,
because when we were growing up,
my stepdad, he used a lot.
I mean, he was high every day,
but he always went to work.
We never were homeless.
We never were out of food.
Like, we always had everything,
but he was always high.
And yeah, he did the whole,
my mom had people living behind the TV
and there was all kinds
of guys everywhere.
And I know that was in his mind,
but when you're small,
you don't know that.
So then when I started using,
I was using with my baby's dad.
I know for a while,
he thought that it was his
fault why I started using,
but I told him, you know, after a while,
it's like you can't force
somebody to get high, you know?
Even if you did encourage it to try it,
it was my choice after
that to keep on using.
And it ended up being a
drug that I loved, you know?
So I've used every day.
And yeah, it got to a point
where I was using with my dad.
Up until the day I got
arrested this last time,
I was with my dad all the time,
always going to work with him,
you know, everything.
It got to a point
where my dad was kind of having problems
with one of my brothers
and his wife decided to call the cops
and kind of say everything.
And she's like, yeah,
well, you know, she's over here.
Like her and her dad
over here are fucking.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Like, bitch.
I had my sisters calling
me, like what the fuck,
talking shit.
And I was like, what the fuck
are you guys talking about?
My mom's calling me, talking shit.
And I was just like,
what in your right fucking
mind makes you think
that I would ever sleep with my dad?
Like I know he's not my real dad,
but he's my dad to me.
I was a little ass girl
when he came into our life,
so to me, that's my dad.
And it was a big issue
because my mom and him
weren't living together.
At the time, she was living in Arizona.
He was living with my brother.
He kind of had the back room.
It was like all the way in the back.
And it was just like, yeah,
I was always with my dad.
Yeah, I could sleep in
the same room as my dad,
but he'll either be on the
bed or on the floor, you know?
Like it was never that type of shit.
And it caused a lot of drama.
Of course, it plants that seed
in people's minds, you know?
Like, okay, well, they're
both not saying it,
but who knows?
It could have happened.
They're both getting high.
People do shit when they're high.
And it was just like, you know.
Yeah, that put a big,
big wall in between me
and a lot of my family members.
And I mean, I ain't got
nothing to lie about.
I know in my heart that
has never happened.
It would never happen.
But yeah, when I went to
jail, my dad got sick.
You know, he was dying.
His heart gave up.
That's when he decided to
change his life around.
And I didn't know nothing about it
until I actually got out of jail.
And he was on all these medications.
He had lost so much weight.
It was kind of an eye opener.
and I was happy to see
that my dad was clean,
but for whatever reason,
it wasn't enough for me.
you know, it wasn't my time yet.
And I would say like,
just because it's around you
or just because you grew up that way,
it doesn't always mean
that you need to follow those same steps.
Everybody still knows
right from wrong, you know?
Even if your whole household does dope
or are gang bangers or whatever,
it's like you get to a certain
age where you know yourself.
Do you want to join this?
Do you want to be a part of it
or do you want to live a different life?
You know?
So I never really blamed like my addiction
or anything that I do on like
from growing up, you know,
because I mean, I don't really
care how stupid you are,
you always know right from wrong.
And of course, I like the adrenaline.
I like the rush.
I like taking risks.
I like doing that I know
I could get caught up for.
And so that's why I
just kinda went with it.
But then, yeah, I have
a problem with authority
so I've just kind of never
did the whole gang thing.
I used to hang around with
them and do certain jobs,
but I never actually became a gang member.
And mainly because I was
just all over the place,
different cities, different hoods.
So it's like,
I can't go to another place
and be like, well, I can't talk
to you 'cause I'm from here.
To me, I don't know
how that, I don't know.
So I never really joined a gang, but yeah.
I mean, I've been around
dope my whole life.
You know, dope, alcohol.
As far as for Mexicans in my family,
you're never really an alcoholic
because everybody drinks.
I think the only person
who's actually ever considered
an alcoholic in my family
was my grandpa.
And that's 'cause he died from it
when I was a little girl,
who also, which I lied to
my mother about this too,
kind of had a breakthrough
when I first got out of jail.
It was Christmas.
And it was just me and
like three of my sisters.
And you know, I guess they were drunk
and they were feeling some type of way,
so feelings started coming out,
and you did this when I was
small, and you did this.
And my mom was like,
well, my whole fear was that
grandpa was gonna do something to you guys
'cause he was a drunk.
Like he didn't know what he was doing.
And I looked at her
and I didn't have the
heart to tell her like,
well, yeah, it did happen.
But I mean, if you were so scared
that he was gonna do something to us,
why did you put us in that situation?
You know what I'm saying?
Why did you have him there?
So that's what I didn't
understand about it
and that's why I didn't
tell her like, yeah,
you know, like he did, he tried.
But to me, that was my grandpa.
And even though I didn't
let him do anything,
I still couldn't be mad at him.
You know, I couldn't hold
a grudge against him.
I didn't have no resentments.
I loved him.
He was grandpa, you know?
It didn't matter what day it was.
He'll take you to the store,
and he'll get his beer and his scratchers,
and he'll let you scratch one.
And that was our day with him, you know?
And it was an everyday thing.
But 'til this day,
my mother does not know that he also tried
and it was around the same time
when their friend had did
what he had did to me.
And I don't know if she'll ever see this,
but I don't think I would ever
have the heart to tell her
because I know that that was
one thing that she feared.
She really broke down
and cried and told us,
like, that was my only fear with you guys.
And I mean, I kind of didn't want to
like throw it in her face type shit,
but I mean, I have daughters too.
And I'm very, very
over-protective with my daughters.
Like, nobody can come near them,
no friends could come to the house.
I have an older son.
He's about to be 17.
He couldn't bring his friends to the house
because I had little girls, you know?
And it's shit like that
that you think every mother would do
to make sure that their
daughters are protected.
And so that's what I
did with my daughters.
And I just feel like that was one part
that she failed to do.
So I just kinda felt like,
well, why are you so like,
you know, why are you crying about it,
why are you making it seem
like it's a big ass deal
when you put us in that
situation, you know?
It's like, so yeah,
It's kinda just been real iffy,
but that's also one of the consequences
of what I put my kids through.
My son is about to be 17
and he's right now in jail.
When I went to jail,
he kind of left the fucking foster system.
He started running away,
started pretty much doing
everything that he seen me do.
Robbing, stealing, doing
shit, hurting other people.
And when I got out of jail,
his father actually got out
a couple of months later,
the one that had 20 years.
And we had children's court.
And I remember I was talking
to my son's grandmother,
and I was like, you know,
is junior gonna come by or whatever?
Like, is he going to court?
And she was like, no.
So when I'm there,
I'm talking to my attorney,
and I turned and I see,
I could have swore it was
my son standing right there.
And I did like a little quick double-take
and I mean, I thought it was my son.
And I looked, and you
know, it was baby daddy.
And I was like, oh shit.
And I hadn't seen him in 15, 16 years.
He was one of those,
obviously, my first love,
what I thought was love.
First person I had ever been with.
It was one of those
like I never wanted
kids with different guys
so I was willing to put up with whatever.
Well, whatever our relationship
was gonna turn out to be,
I was willing to go with it
so that it would just be us, you know?
And I remember his trial went
on for like a year or two
and I was still living with his parents.
But it was everyday like,
you're doing this, you're cheating on me.
Nobody's gonna love you.
Nobody's gonna want you
'cause you have kids.
Like, it was so much.
I was like crying every day.
And then once the year was up,
I was like, you know what?
I'm gone.
Like, I'm the only one
taking care of our son.
I would never ask his parents for nothing.
I never asked them for nothing.
They never paid for nothing.
I would get up everyday, go to school.
I would walk to school or take the bus.
I never asked them for shit
even though I was living at their house.
But I paid for babysitting,
I paid for everything.
There was nothing I asked.
So when that year came up,
I was like what the fuck am I doing?
Like, why am I dealing with his shit?
And this is somebody
I was like willing to wait
the whole 20 years for,
like I was going to be straight, loyal.
Like it's just me and him.
Fuck everybody else.
I don't give a fuck about anybody else.
Like, we'll figure out
ways to make this work.
And after that year, I
was like, man, fuck you.
Like, I'm over here going to school,
going to work, doing all of this,
helping out your family
for you to call me.
Like, he would call like
at least 10 times a day.
I know you're fucking this person.
Like, what the fuck?
Like fool, shut the fuck up.
And I had never, ever, ever
raised my voice at him.
I never yelled at him.
I never cussed at him.
I never nothing.
It was just like, you know,
he'll come home whenever he wanted to.
He'd be like, make this.
I'll make it for him.
We'll fuck, whatever, go to sleep.
The next day, he'll be gone,
and it'll be the same
thing all over again.
And I never said nothing.
And there was girls that
would call at the house.
Like, yeah, I just fucked your man.
Dah, dah, dah.
And he's over here saying
that that baby's not his
and all this bullshit.
And I never said nothing.
I never, never questioned it.
Nothing, until I got tired of it.
And I remember one day, he called,
and I was just like, you know what?
Fuck you.
Fuck everything.
You're no good.
And that was probably the first time
I ever yelled at him, or
cussed at him, or anything.
And he didn't know who I was anymore.
And that's just kind of
how our relationship has been since then.
I never kept my son
from him or his family.
They were more than welcome
to come pick him up,
see him, or take him to go see him.
I never denied him that.
I never spoke to my son about his dad
because I'm not the type to be like,
oh, well, your dad's
this, your dad's that.
Like, no.
Just you, go see your dad.
You have your own opinion.
You have your own relationship with him.
You'll see.
Like when you get older,
you can make that
determination or whatever.
And so when he got out,
I gave up custody to him
because they wanted to
form a bond or whatever.
My son was for it so I told him.
He's older,
so it's not like we gotta
go with what DCFS says,
or anything, or social workers, or courts.
It's basically what my son says
because if not, he'll just
up and leave just like me,
just kinda like how I taught him.
So he's like, yeah, I
want to be with my dad.
Gave up my rights so that
he could go with his dad.
That worked out for about a month or two.
Ran away from dad,
you know, did all this shit.
And now he's in jail, you know?
And it's just the cycle.
It's a cycle that we continue
to fucking, you know,
with every generation.
It's like, when the fuck
does it stop, you know?
It's not the life that I
wanted my kids to have.
It's not the path I
wanted my son to go down.
And it's just like it's
exactly what's happening.
You know?
Just trying to figure out
where I need to be, you know?
I don't know if I'm gonna continue to use
or if I finally get it together,
but that's just part of
being an addict, you know?
You think you hit rock
bottom, but then you don't,
and you just keep going,
and going, and going,
either until you die, or you're
hospitalized, or you know?
That's just it.
So I gotta figure out
where I'm at right now.
- [Interviewer] All
right, well, good luck.
- [Flakah] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you for coming in.
- [Flakah] Yeah, thanks for having me.